what did you learn from crowdfunding
last time you launch the successful
campaign for Kevin our favorite films
what did you learn from that that you're
implementing this time and that you're
also staying away from what worked what
didn't Wow hmm I guess what worked last
time is it was just really personal you
know it was just a personal journey that
I was taking with Kevin at the time you
know we were hemorrhaging money doing it
and we needed support and and so we just
reached out at first to people that who
loved us and we thought would want to
help us get through the journey and and
it ended up you know expanding to so
many more people and it was it was
honestly beyond financially with more
than anything was just the emotional
support of you know trying to do
something really really difficult and
having people back you on it and and say
like we support you and also this is a
good idea and this is important and we
want to see this we want to see this
happen it kind of gave us that boost in
the heart of darkness to kind of keep
going so I mean how that relates to the
Manson project is you know it really is
a super personal project it was born of
my friendship with jay davis who's the
director who you know has a weird
fascination with the Manson Family and
has since he was a kid in the in the yin
and yang between all the horrible things
that they did and also but also the you
know the message is a lot of the
messages are positive that they put out
there and have an environmental
organization and it's it's not totally
one-sided and and I have always been
very disturbed by jay's interest in
man's in it and we've talked about it a
lot and that's kind of how this project
began and so it started really was born
of our friendship and
you know two blocks away at Colombo's
restaurant he told me he was going to
write a script and he wanted me to play
the brother who was going to be
skeptical of the other brother who was
into the Manson Family and I was like I
don't really act that much but I'm gonna
do this I didn't it was one of those
feelings that I had similar to like you
were to you know I was describing to you
about backing a kickstarter project it
was truly just I was inspired by it I
didn't understand why but I just knew I
needed to do it
you